this is every step in the process of
developing a vaccine
from development in the lab testing
approval manufacturing
all the way to getting it to millions of
people
but arguably the most important part is
here
in the human trials where the vaccine is
tested on real people in
three main phases starting with just a
small group of people and ultimately
testing a group of thousands
this is where scientists confirm the
effectiveness and safety of the vaccine
on a
large scale before that scientists
scrutinize its effectiveness
but before any of that a vaccine first
has to pass
this crucial phase where scientists
study the side effects
in a trial you call it adverse events
but that doesn't
that's kind of overstating it dr kirsten
lake led a phase one trial for the
covid19 vaccine made by pfizer and
biontech
she says side effects are a possibility
with any vaccine
in general it's nothing to fear it's our
own immune systems kicking
in and doing what it's supposed to do
the most common flu vaccine this year
for example
comes with a chance for many normal side
effects
pain fatigue headaches
but many of the new kovin 19 vaccines
are more likely to cause these kinds of
side effects than you might be used to
particularly after the second dose most
people will feel a little pain in their
arm
many will be tired and get headaches i
mean obviously
having no side effects is desirable but
i think
with the the spike protein of the
coronavirus it really
does elicit some side effects but that's
totally normal and once you understand
why vaccine side effects happen
you might actually be happy to get them
[Music]
first we have to talk about this your
immune system
which is a huge network of different
cells and proteins in your body
you've got things like white blood cells
that fight the invading virus or
bacteria
communication cells that organize the
response and antibodies that search for
and identify the enemy when
say a virus attacks your body your
immune system attacks back
your body increases blood flow to get
more of these battle cells in
circulation
your temperature might go up too as one
of the tactics your body has to help
kill the invaders
and after your white blood cells destroy
the virus they produce antibodies that
will identify the virus
should it reappear in the future and
remember how to fight it
they're how you gain immunity
this response is actually what gives you
a lot of the symptoms you feel when you
catch
for example the common cold but the cold
virus doesn't give you a fever or a
runny nose or body aches
your immune system does while fighting
the virus
and triggering this system without
actually getting you sick
is how vaccines work most vaccines are
made up of a weakened or dead pathogen
or
a portion of one or in some of the new
coven 19 vaccines
the genetic code of a portion of one
either in the form of dna or what's
called
messenger rna along with minor
ingredients to keep it stable
it's harmless but when your immune
system detects it
it responds just like it's a real danger
it attacks the intruder and creates
these memory antibodies
to be able to fight it again in the
future vaccines are designed to give you
the same immunity as if you would fought
off the real virus
and some of the new coven 19 ones do
this particularly well
messenger rna vaccines are quite good at
stimulating their your immune system
that's why you have 95
efficacy that's right a 95
chance of being protected against
covid19 that makes them some of the most
effective vaccines
but that also means they're really good
at activating your immune system
which means your body will increase
blood flow to where the vaccine is
which is why pain at the injection site
is so common
your body might even think better turn
up the heat and then you get a fever or
the chills
so experts emphasize that we should look
at most side effects as a
good thing it means the vaccine is
working
i have a friend actually who
participated in one of the pfizer trials
early trials and
you know so he could have gotten either
placebo or vaccine or after the second
dose
the next day he woke up and he had he
was sort of fatigued and he had low
grade fever and he looked at his wife
and said yes
i got the vaccine see that's the right
attitude
when we talk about these common
reactions to vaccines like
fever and fatigue we're mostly talking
about the mild to moderate ones
these are the lowest of the side effect
categories that health regulators use
the kind you get over in a day or two
then there's severe side effects the
type that might make you call in sick to
work or call a doctor
these were rare in the clinical trials
for the first two studied vaccines to
become available
with the exception of some severe
fatigue and muscle pain on the second
dose
and that's because if these vaccines
were dangerous they'd
never reach the public in the first
place we really don't accept any sort of
permanent serious harm from a vaccine
and nor should we
new stories that imply otherwise can be
scary but they get more attention than
they probably deserve
like this one about a serious allergic
reaction
in someone with a history of serious
allergic reactions
or this one about someone dying after
getting a second dose of the vaccine
when it turned out other factors had
caused his death
in fact no deaths have been reported
from the millions of doses
that have been given out and the
controlled studies with
thousands of people found the same thing
no deaths from the vaccine
but maybe more importantly the studies
also recorded
zero deaths from coven 19 and
zero hospitalizations from kova 19.
these vaccines aren't just safe they're
lifesavers
you should be skeptical of anything you
put in your body including vaccines
once you've seen the data and you see
that there wasn't a serious side effect
before
approval and and hasn't been a serious
side effect post-approval then i think
you should be convinced
basically you want to reduce where the
virus can go
and if you immunize as many people as
possible that pool of people that it can
transmit to
becomes less and less and less and less
vaccines are the way out of the coven 19
pandemic
and like with all vaccines many of us
who get it will also feel a little
meh for a day or two but the scientists
who have studied these vaccines
who have seen the side effects are some
of the most
eager to get it i couldn't wait to get
this vaccine are you kidding me i mean
two doses of vaccine gives me a 95
chance of of being protected we would be
the first ones to not want to take it if
we felt it was unsafe right
so um take it from your friendly vaccine
person
[Music]